that there's one franchise i mean i was
looking at that
look at all 32 nfl teams all of them
okay
i would say the lowest of the low is the
lines
first of all never been to a super bowl
haven't won a championship since 57
and hadn't sniffed one since and
every other franchise throughout the nfl
you can point to
you could point to a high mark in modern
times
you know even even the jaguars had a
moment where they were on the cusp of
being so they went to afc championship
game for crying out loud and now they're
about to get
uh trevor lawrence the panthers have
they had the cam new narrator they went
to two super bowls for crying out loud
and they they started what 96 so that's
those two teams
the texas have deshawn watson finally
for now
[Laughter]
you know i mean every other team you can
point to the browns are back the browns
left they're back there in the playoffs
every other team you could point to has
had a moment of excitement but the lions
have been perpetually dysfunctional
disappointing uh they too look man two
hall of famers decided you know what i
can't take this no more
calvin johnson and embarrassment but
they had them at least they had those
they had them they had them i wouldn't
it's been down
but you can't you can't say houston has
had excitement because of deshaun wagner
but okay
but they get it calvin johnson
exceptions
that's an exception billy okay but at
least houston just got here
houston just got here yesterday they
just got that team yesterday okay so
there's that so when you compare it to
50 some of our years 60 years
of just can't get out of their own way
yeah there's no comparison to the to the
type of
just disappointment and pain and angst i
mean we can clown the browns
and the chargers the charters went to
super bowl in 94. we could clown those
scenes all about the falcons
the falcons got 28 3. the falcons said
michael vick i know it ended badly but
every other team you could point to and
see something
or at least make an excuse whereas the
lions just
but today my friend but today
dad campbell
if you haven't seen it and you need to
pick me up here's new lions head coach
dan campbell this place has been kicked
it's been battered it's been bruised
and i can sit up here and give you coach
speak all day long i can give you uh
you know hey we're gonna win this many
games i can't but none of that matters
and you guys don't want to hear it
anyway
you've had enough of that so excuse my
language
all right here's what i do know is that
this team is going to take on the
identity of this city
all right and the city's been been down
and it found a way to get up
all right it's found a way to uh
overcome adversity
all right and so this team is going to
be built on uh we're going to kick you
in the teeth
all right and when you punch his back
we're going to smile at you and when you
knock us down
we're going to get up and on the way up
we're going to bite a knee cap off
all right and we're going to stand up
and then it's going to take two more
shots to knock us down
all right and on the way up we're going
to take your other kneecap and we're
going to get up and then it's going to
take three shots to get us down
and when we do we're going to take
another hunk out of you before before
long where they're going to be the last
one standing
all right that's going to be the
mentality so
our man's got a map that's why he's got
a math problem
well no well he was he was describing
an experience that was oddly specific
clearly that was a fight that he was
recalling in real time
because that was like like seen moment
by moment it's like
that was graphic and i loved every
second of it but a kneecap he won
the lions don't win much but they won
the press conference
we'll see if they won the hiring cycle
we'll see if they win the division again
anytime soon they did have the wayne
fontes years which were fun with barry
sanders but none of the
running shoes but nonetheless like we
will see what happens
and i know it's just a press conference
and i know coaches
they always say what needs to be said
but man if he wasn't speaking to the
soul of that city just now
he was speaking to the soul of that city
and michael
listen man eventually they got to get it
right huh
i mean we we'll talk i'm sure the colts
got their coach today
and um and maybe i haven't talked to you
before now
maybe we talk about the fact that we're
down to the texans
for eric the enemy or a black head coach
for that matter
yeah so right that's that's what we're
counting on maybe and
we can we can talk about that but i do
want to focus for this moment on
michael yeah sometimes we forget who
actually did get the job
and i think you could be frustrated by
the lack of diversity
at the head coaching and general manager
level by the way i'll get to the lions
gym in a second you can be frustrated by
that but at the same time recognize
that the lions at least based on first
impressions maybe they got a good one
what no okay no no okay i didn't know
you were going to say that
i know that was going to be your walk up
i don't know i said a lot which part
no nobody knows look like i said maybe i
don't know i said maybe
based on first impressions nobody knows
he may be just the latest in a long line
of lions failures
i don't know of course i don't know that
i'm saying i can like
dance and still be frustrated about the
fact that
no black coaches have been hired and
look like they won't be hired at all
this this this
this cycle that i'm saying one i'm gonna
say i'm gonna say dan campbell got a
good one because he got a six year
contract
first year head coach six year contract
that's a good deal yeah uh
secondly very entertaining i enjoyed
every minute
of that press conference came out
wearing
uh detroit's colors that's a nice touch
and as you said
you know spoke to the to the football
fans of detroit
and and said some things that they
wanted to hear michael hey real quick
let me correct myself i'm sorry
i misspoke the eagles have their coach
they hired the colts offensive
coordinator i'm
sorry about that talking too fast yeah
they hired the coastal
eagles have their coach so we're down to
texas but continue sorry
yeah so i mean i think he did speak to
uh lions fans but you know what
mike i think a lot of i think you spoke
to lions fans off the top
it's he said they're tired of talking
they're tired of hearing all this stuff
i think they're tired of it it's as
entertaining as that was
that's not gonna get it done in detroit
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you